101的铺长
这个39扣1
39块扣1扣1
39 39扣个1
来这一条
这条是一个条尾的一个小码
条尾的一个小码
黑黑灰条
米色和黑色条
腰尾62
62 78
臀尾
臀尾90 104
单长35扣长87
这个9块
9块扣个1
9块9块扣1扣1
9块钱9块钱扣个1扣个1
来这一块
这个是一个黑白条尾的这一块
后半边松你的一条哈林裤
来腰尾
腰尾64 64到80
臀尾
臀尾10
腰尾114
当场36
后场98
这个9块扣个8
OZOC的好像是都是
牌子在里面
M吗
OZOC的这一块
来这个9块9块扣1扣1
9块钱扣个1
扣2
扣3
扣4
扣5
扣6
扣7
扣8
扣9
扣11
扣12
扣13
扣14
扣15
扣16
扣17
扣19
扣20
扣21
扣22
扣23
扣24
扣25
扣26
扣27
扣28
扣30
扣31
扣32
扣33
扣34
扣35
扣36
扣37
扣39
扣40
扣41
扣42
扣43
扣45
扣46
扣47
扣49
扣50
扣51
扣52
扣53
扣54
扣55
扣56
扣67
扣89
扣10
扣11
扣12
扣13
扣14
扣15
扣16
扣17
扣18
扣19
扣20
扣21
扣22
扣23
扣24
扣25
扣26
扣27
扣28
扣29
扣30
扣31
扣32
扣33
扣34
扣35
扣36
扣37
扣38
扣39
扣40
扣41
扣42
扣43
扣44
扣45
扣46
扣47
扣48
扣49
扣50
扣51
扣52
扣53
扣54
扣55
扣56
扣57
扣58
扣59
扣60
扣61
扣62
扣32
扣33
扣34
扣35
扣36
扣37
扣38
扣39
扣40
扣41
扣42
扣43
扣44
扣45
扣46
扣47
扣48
扣49
扣51
扣52
扣53
扣54
扣56
扣57
扣58
扣59
扣60
扣61
扣32
扣33
扣34
扣35
扣36
扣37
扣38
扣39
扣40
扣41
扣42
扣43
扣44
扣45
扣46
扣47
扣48
扣49
扣50
扣51
扣52
扣53
扣54
扣55
扣56
扣57
扣58
扣59
扣32
扣35
扣36
扣37
扣38
扣39
扣40
扣41
扣42
扣43
扣44
扣45
扣46
扣47
扣49
扣51
扣52
扣53
扣54
扣56
扣27
扣26
福利29哭零29块
哭零哭零
你看呗
这个膝盖这个位置
以一个上面有一条这个
颜色浅的一条线
哭零哭零
29块哭个零
来这一个这个是
这个是有裤
有风衣裤有拉链
后面面松紧的一个白色裤子
白色一条裤来腰围
腰围是68 68 84
68 84 腿围
腿围114120
当场37
裤长100
这个39块
哭一哭一
39 39
哭个一哭个一
39块哭一哭一
我天呐
高货这条裤子又出来一条
这个不是高货
这个是大爆板
大爆板大爆板
这个原来卖39的这条裤
后来放福利29卖了一段时间
就这一条了应该
矮喽吃满了
这个牌子
这个牌
这个牌这个牌
嗯这个有没有深色的
就刚刚那个白色那一款吗
还是说的这个
这都是孤行千难
过到一条
就是一条没地方找去
深色裤子也有很多
你得蹲
l 号你能穿过你两辆
这个9块钱给你
腰围64
l 号能穿这个才64
64-98的腰
64 98腿围
腿围98124
当场当场34
裤长是95
尺寸能穿不
残原服
9块钱给你9块
你74的腰这个才64的平坡
64但是他能拉
这个弹力好
你看这个前面都是弹力这个腰
来9块了给你了就这一条
说很久没看了没见了
来366
366谢谢
谢谢谢谢
谢谢漂亮
9块
6元39
方幅29卖了一段时间
这一段时间都没见了他
没见了这个裤
好的
ok
好多钱
,来这个这个大码高腰的高腰的这一条大扩的员
这个尺码大应该
这个应该是个背带裤
但是上面没有带的标的是lp
lp是个啥牌子
不是是个啥码吗了
来这个是有扣的应该是个背带裤
腰围并不80能拉伸106
腿围腿围102116
单长45
裤长的话是105
这个给你们一个29块
能穿扣2
这个应该是3l的
这个是lp的应该是3l的一个尺码
这个本身是一个背带裙
但他没有带子
这只能当裤子穿
29你们29扣个2
29块扣2扣2
来这一条直筒直筒一条黑色
黑色大裤嘴的
大裤嘴的这条裤的
全松紧又抽绳的黑色的
来看洗标
l尺码一个锯子的
l尺码一个锯子牌子这个牌子的
这个牌来腰围量一下
腰围68
68-100
全围120
116-126的
单长37裤长是97
这个39扣1啊
大裤腿的39
扣个1
39块扣1扣1
39块扣个1
来这一款
这个是一个灰色
威喇威喇的一条后半边松紧的
来这个腰围
腰围64
64-90
腿围
腿围11啊
98-104
单长36
裤长100
这个39扣6
灰色的一条
稀阔
39扣6扣6
39块扣个6扣个6
39扣个6
这有一个灰色的一个小吊带
他俩放在一起的
我看看
颜色差不多
但是好像有一点点误差
不知道能配一套不
反正颜色不仔细看看不出来
能配一套不
这一款也是一个灰色的一个小吊带
外穿了一个吊带
腰上有腰带的
胸围86
86-98
86-98群一长
一长56的一长56
这个29
29扣2
29块扣2扣2这一块
2929扣个2扣个2
来这一款
这个是一个卡其色一个大扣的一扣
L尺码一个距着的
L尺码一个距着
牌子这个牌子的
来腰尾看一下全送你
腰尾62 62-98
平尾
平尾116120
端长37扣长96
来这个有腰的39扣6
39块扣6扣6
嗯咔嗦
咔嗦
叉瑟的叉瑟的
这个裤子有五个颜色的
五个颜色这一条裤尺码都不大
都小但他版型很好看
这个裤子版型超好
来货的时候我就看上了
但是没有一条能穿得进来
腰尾60
60-70的腰
60-70这个裤长大概是93的一个长度
这个最大尺码就是62-74的腰了
这个39扣3
30-70的腰
39块扣个3
有黑色有米色
嗯这个是个杏色还有一个咔色
还有个灰五个颜色
版型很好
这条裤子好多姐妹都买了好几条
对腰尾小这个腰尾都小
都是小码s码均码
最大就是均码了
均码62-74的腰
就算是最大的了
这个每一条我都量过
是吗就这几个是吗
你看
这个版型可好了
有好多小码能穿的姐姐都扣了好几条
每个颜色都好看
还有一个这个颜色
那个灰色和白色
扣的人超多
嗯咔色的话就那刚刚那个浅色看了扣的人多
版型都好
都是64
呃6060-70的腰
最大的60-62
62-74
可惜都小
来这个
这一款这个是一个哈林裤
这个是个哈林裤M码
巨指72
人面23
圈子5
这是啥牌子
来腰尾
跑步了
你这一穿那你这这不都瘦了你
哎呦
你穿一样咸的咱们也要瘦那些
咸的这有戏的
以前没有穿完这样的衣裳啊
来这个腰尾
然后这个腰尾
腰尾66-90
66-90好
腿尾腿尾100-110
当场当场35
护长91
来这个39块
扣个1
发货了发货了姐妹们还有谁没付款呢不
去付款发货
来这个39块
抠1这个不好
这个有一点点粉粉的
哎
粉粉呢
这个好像能洗掉
扣一下就淡了
扣一下淡了一点
你看见没有
淡了很多
还有一点点粉
这个29给你们放个不列
29扣1扣1
米色米色的
29块扣个1
不知道沾了啥粉粉的
那个能洗掉
扣一下都掉了
29块扣1扣1
来这个L号
后半边松紧
大阔腿的一条
这个是小角的
小角的一个西装裤
尺筒
小角腰围
腰围的话是
70到80
腿围106112
当长35
裤长91
来这个39块
扣1扣1
扣1
39块扣个1
这个是M码
棉60
这个是据指38
据案指3
据案指2
这个牌
棉68的
藏蓝色
藏蓝色的这一条
这个是后半边松紧的
一个哈林裤
面料面料是棉68的
腰围60